[Music]
hello welcome to our final fantasy
launch day live stream i'm chastity this
is all delivered by pizza hut and i'm
joined today by a very special guest
trisha hershberger is here
oh shall i say tifa
you are just like that yeah for sure one
of my favorite characters ever from
final fantasy yeah yours too uh
definitely i i would say tifa and lulu
from final fantasy 10 are probably my
toss-ups but yeah definitely one of my
faves and we're about to jump into this
brand new final fantasy are you excited
i can't wait all right
and before we do i just want to show you
this so this is a custom pizza hut xbox
one controller and you can win one of
these
with an xbox one s from pizza hut
they're giving away every hour i'm gonna
give you the details a little bit later
you have to stay tuned so keep watching
and i'll tell you how to win but a
little clue it involves the pizza hut
triple treat box are you hungry yeah you
keep talking about pizza huts
i'm gonna order this one go ahead and
jump into the game so let's get started
we're not that far into the game we are
here at the beginning so we just pushed
a car along we met cindy and we
killed some little pests for her so now
we're on some side quests just going to
investigate oh i think i probably can't
run through this wall to that side that
would be really cool if you just break
through that
excuse me excuse me bro excuse me bros
um yeah one of the things i was reading
about this game is that the camera while
amazing for open world and outdoors when
you are inside like we were just wearing
that yeah it's a little bit wonky it is
a little wonky
how much hands-on time have you had with
final fantasy only i just started
playing so i've only had
an hour with it so far okay but i like
it a lot and i'm also a big final
fantasy fan ignis wants to talk to us
and he went up the glasses so he's
obviously this he's the smart one on the
team this is our boy band this is our
k-pop group and he is the smart one on
the team and just so you guys know we
are also on twitch and youtube right now
we want to chat with you we want to take
all your questions just let us know what
you think of final fantasy 15 you have
any questions for trish over here or
tifa let us know and we will talk to you
guys on twitch and youtube but first i'm
hungry trish is hungry so i'm gonna call
up the pizza hut app and i'm gonna order
us a triple treat box and noctis is
hungry too because i just ordered food
with ignis oh nice get ready for this
let's get ready all right so i'm gonna
get our triple treat box ready
so
your dress is tifa what kind of topping
would tifa want
what kind of topping yeah one um well
tifa is a pretty active lady
she can jump higher and oh my gosh her
moves boom boom
um i'm going to say that since she's
most likely very into fitness she would
probably go with a veggie pizza it's a
good choice it's a good choice yeah
we'll go with the veggie pizza so the
triple treat box comes with
two medium one-topping pizzas
breadsticks with marinara sauce and also
the ultimate hershey's chocolate chip
cookie so i hope you're ready for all
that food so since we have one pizza
each tifa is getting a veggie pizza okay
great and i think we should order one on
behalf of noctis our hero in the game
what kind of topping would he like he's
kind of browy what do you think well i
think i think uh for this bromance maybe
let's do standard pepperoni how's that
yeah that sounds like a good shareable
topping for our bros over here so now
just make sure
even though i'm dressed as teeth i can
still eat noctis's pizza right yes okay
you can still eat noctis's pizza i will
also eat both pizzas okay
as well all right
we're gonna make camp up here that is
ordered food's on the way let's jump
into final fantasy 15 see what we're up
to we're going to enjoy a status
boosting mule so they're going to eat
we're going to eat it's all the same and
let's check out what's going on in chat
so we're on youtube and twitch hanging
out while we're playing final fantasy
uh someone asked playing on pc no we're
playing on xbox one the very xbox one s
that we got thanks to pizza hut this was
all delivered by pizza hut so thanks
guys
and
let's see tifa is the best says nachi jr
we agree hello trish for watching
trish your tifa cosplay is amazing thank
you
thank you so much this is one of the
first cosplays that i ever built
um and it's a it's a closet cosplay so
when you're first getting into cosplay i
don't know how much you cosplay i
cosplay but yeah i'm i do it like once
or twice a year because of work but yeah
and i think there's a lot of people who
get overwhelmed and think oh there's
such amazing costumers out there
i could never even be on the same level
as them and to that i say that's
completely okay because if you love the
character then go be the character
matter
you know what level of costuming you're
at and every every level or every
cosplay you do gets a little bit better
yeah you know so when i say start
cosplay i mean i took things from my
closet and then altered the crap out of
them that's so great to me
yeah it totally works
all right
ignis uses ingredients to prepare his
meals to camp require new recipes to
expand his cookbook this is so perfect
they're going to get me so hungry for
this pizza
yeah it looks like is that ramen down
there he's got an egg on something i
love putting an egg on anything whenever
there's an option to put an egg like on
a burger
attack boost if we get that what else
can he make what so flame roasted toast
toasty rice balls
toasty rice
not a croque monsieur a croque medan
it's got an egg on it that's got my
voice it does or he can make veggie
medley stew okay so we can either get an
attack and eat oh man oh man well i
think we should probably cook his
fanciest thing get fancy with him so
we'll get a level two attack boost and a
level three hp boost heck yes treat
yourself miss do it
to some good food and some good attack
boosts i like a guy that can cook i do
ignore my favorite i've only been
playing this game for about five minutes
and ignis is my favorite aegis is the
best member of this boy band so far
because he can cook for us look at that
wow that's pretty good that looks pretty
good i would eat that delicious
okay i love what there is
i love this food in this game it's so
perfect it's gonna get me so hungry okay
all right let's see what's going on get
everybody hanging out camping oh look
they're telling campfire stories what
kind of stories do you think they're
telling right now i don't know yeah uh
for everyone who's listening to the
stream right now we can't hear their
banter
so we don't know we have to make it up
yeah okay um
let's see i'm checking out the chat i'm
over on youtube right now to see how
everyone's doing
tony said trisha
and derek said trish you look stunning
as always you're so
nice you they're loving the cosplay
i'm such a fan of cosplay it's so much
fun me too i have so much fun
what's been your favorite cosplay to do
so far oh my gosh
um i well i've been trying to do a
jessica rabbit for years but i haven't
done it successfully let's look at these
photographs yeah so these are snapshots
oh you can share them on social media
that's cool
we'll do that hey look it's there's me
there's cindy our buddy she's got some
big old baboons
she's great
she's fantastic
she's the only lady we've seen so far in
the game
look at that picture
they don't look as ridiculous there they
look ridiculous they do they do thanks
final fantasy
i like it i like it
she's our mechanic if you guys haven't
seen any game play yet cindy's the
mechanic now chastity you were playing
earlier yeah and you
met up with cindy and she told me to
kill some yeah she told me to kill some
pests that were around the area so we
can make a little bit of side money
because we were absolutely poor we're a
pauper prince and our squad a little bit
of side gill yeah okay so we've got a
camp up here did we just leave our
camper can we pick it up
press a
camp train nothing yeah i guess we just
leave it okay well we're
we're bad we're bad kids just leave our
campers
we're just trashing the camp sorry guys
trash in the camp yep hey let's go make
some gill let's make some gifts we need
something over here
and a quarter mile away from us roughly
yep
so okay these are the items we have
right now we have six potions we got
some phoenix down just in case just in
case we get into some trouble yep
if you guys are new to final fantasy
this is a pretty
good game to just start off with like
it's very friendly they are advertising
it as for new fans and old
of final fantasy so you can just jump
right in there's a lot of training so
like right off the bat they give you a
whole training section they show you how
to do battles
completely different in this game anyway
so it's not like yeah you don't need to
know how to combat from beforehand
because they'll start you off with the
training right off the front anyway
what did you think of the the combat
training when you were doing it earlier
uh so i just went through the combat
tutorial and uh it was okay
um you know it's pretty complex and can
be a bit overwhelming at first but i
have a feeling after you know hours and
hours and hours which is the final
fantasy game so i'm expecting hours and
hours and years
you'll get the hang of it and probably
those complexities will be what makes it
more fun i don't know if you played the
game transistor at all no but when i
first started playing that game it was
so the combat system was so overwhelming
to me and by the time i got to the end
of the game i couldn't wait for combat
because i was so into the combat system
so i have a feeling this is going to be
the same way
um although i'm a rare bird in that
probably my favorite
final fantasy combat system was that
featured in 10 because it was super
turn-based it returned back to the uog
and i love that
most people don't like turn-based though
they get a little boring yeah i like it
i'm used to i'm used to it like i'm fine
either way oh we've got a big one all
right big guy right here all right
our first foray into battle on this
stream
and we of course we come across a really
big really a really big enemy did he
just kill it with one hit
he just kind of knocked him down so in
combat you only control noctis yes so
i'm like you can warp up there yes my
friends can perform special techniques
to aid me
okay
another thing to think about
yay over on youtube they're asking what
platform is this we are playing on the
xbox one s we indeed are yep that's why
it looks so good okay come on and you
can win one of your own from pizza hut
we're gonna tell you how to do that a
little bit later when our pizza arrives
what i'm trying to do right now is
point warp out of the way and then
attack him from time like this because
you get a warp strike
yeah oh no oh didn't see him right now
oh no
laughs get out of there man if you use
your left bumper you can get your
friends to do a special on him but you
have to be down on the ground i think
okay and it uses up some of your keys go
in there
so pick which one you want so igoris is
gonna attack him in the butt oh
for a sweet attack in the butt
so you get it that's not that's how you
get out of there so when you hang up
here like this you actually regain uh
both mp and hp which is great nice
i'm just gonna go for a little a little
swinging swinging a hit swing and
okay sirs let's get out of here
so this is noctis ability not everyone
can warp so this is the war
warp strike
i guess let's go for the head princess
i'm up there it's ballsy oh i'm in
stasis now that's not good oh yeah so we
have to regain our mp
so you can crash behind a rock and like
hit x and i think that helps you a
little bit well that regains it
instantaneously oh nice if you point
warp it brings all your mp back or yeah
you can crouch behind something and it
does it little by little
yes that is true okay we're over on
gamespot and youtube if you guys want to
hang out with us please leave your
comments and questions about final
fantasy xv you guys are awesome said mr
clark cody thank you thanks clark cody
all right so nice hey we just defeated a
big monster we did it on my cell phone
and call my lady oh hey so we can't hear
we can't hear the
what they're talking about that's going
on right now you guys could probably
hear this is going to his wedding
he is he's going to wed a lovely lady
and so
we are trying to get to her but first we
have to get some guilt because we're
very poor and our car is getting
repaired we had to push it down the road
it's very difficult he's having a tough
having a tough day let's see what gear
we have right now we probably don't have
a ton but i want to check it out yeah
let's check it out yeah let's show them
this main menu so this is where we have
the gear and we can equip for our
buddies so we're going to look at noctis
primary arms right now
he's got looks like an engine blade a
javelin a two-handed sword
and we've got an empty slot down here so
let's just see we don't have any other
swords we've got our two-handed sword
we've got a javelin that's already
equipped we've got daggers firearms yeah
none of that yet we're just waiting we
do have a fire spell however so i'm
gonna make sure that that's ready to go
that's good in case we need it that's a
good spell to use right yes
back to business i'm gonna make it my
javelin because i think it looks really
cool it does look pretty rad
achievement unlocked quadruple threat
very nice question from cool whip what
do you guys think about cloud being in
super smash brothers
i like plows i like clouds i'm a fan
yeah i'm down with it that's fine i
prefer bayonetta when i'm playing super
smash brothers over cloud
in terms of new characters oh yeah i'm
not the wii fit trainer no
not super down with sweet it is pretty
funny to beat everyone if we fit trainer
and then to have you everyone lose
because of we fit trainer is is pretty
satisfying i love a good troll character
to beat everyone with what are these
guys
bird beast eggs oh wait did we do
anything with honey
i don't know but i'd like to grab them
please get out of the way yeah i think
they're worth something or we can use
them to cook
oh maybe do you think we can cook with
them all right i don't think we can pick
up anymore all right because they don't
have a
glowy blue light anymore
all right so we gotta go around this
rock let's follow our marker and see
what we're up to next
so if you guys are just tuning in we're
playing final fantasy 15 delivered by
pizza hut we are ordering
some delivery for ourselves actually
we're getting a triple treat box which
comes with a lot of yummy food and
inside that triple treat box there's a
code
to win a final not a final fantasy but a
xbox one s and a custom pizza hut
controller we're to tell you where to
find that code and more details about
that giveaway when the pizza arrives so
keep watching can we show off that
controller yeah we can here it is check
it out
this is what you can win we are giving
you the details when our pizza arrives
so keep watching stay tuned i have not
actually gotten hands-on with an xbox
one s yet really so here it is
here we go here we go
he's telling me oh something isn't
coming watch out block lock no be
careful
all right are we gonna have to fight him
let's find out i'm hoping that's a good
guy i'm hoping he just lands and is like
i'm hoping
are you here to help or not come on no
please let us know
okay well now we're just watching that
just happened okay that was just an
encounter cool on youtube fahad mv said
wow nice how much does this game cost it
is 59.99
full price
and it's available now today today is
launch day so there you go you know what
i have to say about the video games
industry over time that i'm impressed
with
games like back in the day like when we
were kids yes games cost like 50 bucks
yeah they did today this many years
later games still cost like 50 bucks
pretty standard so like you know
aaa's like this where you're like i've
been waiting 10 years maybe 59.99 yeah
but still
pretty good pretty good
someone said wow this is a lot of
running yeah it is
it's a very open world they took that
quite seriously well and it would
normally be a lot of driving or yeah
once we get a car we'll be able to drive
around but i'm hoping at some point in
the 10th chocobo riding yes there should
be chocobo riding so let's get back to
wherever we need to go to get our car i
think cindy should be an hour
okay hopefully
let's find out now it says we're doing
the mutant marauder retrieve the regalia
oh interesting yes okay let's do this
quest first and then we'll all right
hopefully see what that quest is so we
know what's going on yeah all right
let's see what we got
the mutant murad rotter
dave informs the group of a mutant dual
horn running amok for a challenge noctis
agrees to take it down cool let's take
it down we'll probably get some money we
need money to pay for our car repairs
anyway
so that's what's going to happen road
tripping
your car breaks down what do you do yep
you run around and go camping with your
bros until you've made enough kill to
fix your car
okay here's an outpost this is
that's my buddy hey buddy
now have you played long enough that you
really know these four characters yet no
not at all i don't know the
what they're all about i don't know
their personalities quite well yet
okay
it says restaurants speak to the
tipsters to learn about the area okay
let's just we're gonna go right for it
right now cindy here we go
hey girl
okay we did it yay all right
what's up cindy
so we're over on twitch and
youtube right now if you guys want to
ask us any questions let's see what's
going on over on twitch
cooperative mode or not uh nope no
cooperative look she's going to take a
cool picture of us hey we're here
hey
thank
you
making a little delivery for me
someone over on twitch
said first cooperative mode is intense
choreographed dancing i wish
all right would you all mind making a
little delivery for me should we say yes
or ask friends uh let's see what our
friends say okay
i'm going to have to ask my friend
[Music]
his hair is crazy
his hair is so cute
i love it
ignis has something to say but we don't
know quite what it is yet
okay now that she's all polished up and
ready for the road would you care to
take her for a little test
drive um
yep take your first bit yeah let's take
it for a spin
i want to see it okay you haven't driven
it all yet no i've only pushed the car i
have not driven yet okay
this is all new to
me drive to the rest area yeah
we're getting our car
this is my car huh
very nice oh the regalia is our car the
regalia okay
oh my goodness are you ready for this oh
manuel so otto selects a destination and
has ignis drive us there
i think we should check out manual
uh i'm probably gonna be awful
anytime i ever play grand theft auto i
run into everything i just drive into
everything pretty much
so let's anticipate that here okay we
got our learner's permit
oh nope that gets out of the car that is
not the gas let's try again
i like those sweet doors though
someone's asking if you know spanish do
i know spanish no i wish i did
my little sister speaks spanish fluently
and i was very jealous that's impressive
right
okay so it looks like right trigger is
gas
and uh
right analog stick is someone else wants
you to say something in spanish i don't
know what their fixation is
do you like action-based combat or
turn-based combat dragon king asked i
like turn-based combat yeah
this is all action but i hear this is a
really nice combat system so i'm stoked
i like both i'm currently still playing
dishonored 2 and i love it
um yeah so that's a lot of fun i love
the combat in that but yeah turn based
combat is also fun it's kind of what i
was raised when i played a couple of
final fantasies in my day
right
so
yeah it just makes me think of all those
old sweet games
i also play a lot of uh turn-based
strategy
like here's my magic and that kind of
stuff so yeah back in the crown city
i think i'd better i like taking i like
it to be like a chess game where i can
take time to strategize and
outwit my opponent yeah as opposed to
being purely reflex-based but combat
systems like this that combine the two
are always an interesting challenge
baptist said lol they're controlling a
boy band yeah pretty much we're straight
up about
oh gosh i did not choose to do that it
chose to do that for me
i'm still controlling it i don't know
why i did that so he said now this is a
boy band video yeah this reminds me of
bye bye bye bye and saying
when lance and jc are in the car okay we
are not going the direction that i need
us to go
now we've passed do we have to fill gas
yeah we do oh my god yes do you see a
gas meter
i'm going to try turning around on the
left yeah scary terrain
oh you see gas on the left yeah there's
a little
thing on the left screen
but i don't see where the marker is it
seems to be fine okay i hope orange is
good yeah i think orange okay so here's
a parking spot
okay well that was fun do you want to
try driving
i'm good okay yeah so what i'm gonna do
is get out of the car
okay there we go good good is this where
we need to be or we're close okay no
we're not really okay that's how you
turn around apparently interesting i
thought i was getting out of the car
that's
uh so i guess let's go ahead and drive
back towards our marker yeah let's drive
towards our marker oh that's what i was
trying to do initially i was going to
say let's just jump out of the car and
let ignis take a step
can ignis drive the car he can so that
was our other option okay we didn't want
to do it ourselves
but i thought let's check it out yeah
pretty it kind of keeps you on the road
like right now i'm not really steering
and it's just kind of doing its own
thing yeah just holding the gas
so that's pretty nice if you don't want
to worry about running into everything
that's probably why it took me up that
little road
even though that's not really where i
wanted to go
okay so let's go on this road we seem to
be going in the right direction now this
is good and you know with the right
amount of banter and uh good soundtrack
yeah just driving could be really fun
yeah it could just turn into a driving
game
driving sim all day
you can change the camera with l1 we're
playing on the xbox park
okay i'm parking at the rest stop here
we go
we made it
guys everyone was waiting for us we
finally the errand prince speak to the
motel manager
mark is asking how far into the game are
you this is pretty much the beginning we
haven't gotten that far this is pretty
much like a half hour in so you're not
that far after the tutorial or if you
skipped the tutorial it's just a couple
of missions
off we only did a couple of side
missions
we only made a little bit of money we
got our car so it's very early in the
game
now we're talking to our hotel manager
cool man
so we're also on youtube and twitch oh
puppy so hang out with us on youtube and
twitch and leave us your questions talk
about final fantasy what are your guys's
final fantasy favorite characters or
favorite favorite game i always tell me
your favorite game yes tell me what your
favorite final fantasy game is let's
talk about that in the chat i want to
hear it i love to hear people argued
about ooh look at this 12 years earlier
flashback uh oh oh look at that
so this is our bride to be look at her
she's lovely
she's very cute
look he still had nicely qualified he's
pretty much had the same haircut his
entire life now it's spikier so now
there's more product in it for sure
cheese plate said this is just like that
britney spears movie where they take a
road trip crossroads 2002 oh my god
played her dad
it was such a weird movie that's super
weird
well we were right back finally going to
see you after all these years just left
the crown city or got it
let's be romantic romantic we're going
romantic finally gonna see you after all
these years every note we write is going
to be super sappy and gross and she's
not going to want to marry us anymore
well talking about favorite final
fantasy games one of the reasons i like
tens so much is the love story i'll be
perfectly honest oh
it makes me cry a little bit oh i'm not
gonna lie when i beat the game i didn't
cry a little bit a little shut a little
tear i know yeah
i love a good love story
me too and final fantasy i definitely
love a good long story very well yeah
they do
let's do it
all the names of these are really funny
oh look what's coming in the pizza thank
you
we'll show that to you in just a bit
pizza pizza let's play through in a
little bit and see what we can find here
oh my gosh that looks so good i'm so
distracted by the pizza i just ran
knocked us right into it
okay should we drive to this spot or run
to it
it's a mile and a half maybe we should
drive let's drive let's save some time
we're going to be here for another hour
so
we've got some time but let's let's get
things along
okay so is that where we're going
a blockade
quest location
is there
okay
the aaron prince let's do it it's a two
minute drive i'm letting ignis
drive he's going to take the wheel now
i'm going to take the wheel
indeed all right he's driving he's a
much better driver than i am i'm just
going to kick back and enjoy the scenery
on our drivers
yeah this is so beautiful i love the
look of this game it's gorgeous
especially on the xbox one s right now
this is the best way we could probably
play this
oh thanks for
driving us this is so much easier we're
just sitting back nice
it really is a beautiful life i will be
unable to fulfill my duties with oracle
now i have not done a lot of research as
to where they base this terrain on if
it's based on an actual location i think
it is based on actual locations i think
there was a like behind the scenes video
that they made for the making of this
yeah and yeah they went they scouted
real locations
and they were like fairly dangerous
locations too so like it was very
adventurous really yeah
well yeah if anyone on chat knows what
those locations are yeah please let us
know let's talk about their favorite
final fantasies okay we've got final
fantasy vii yep uh final fantasy 8 10
from v live tv
10's a good one
v live tv said 10 is the best jacked was
the man yes jack was there yeah yep lots
of seven
uh seven nine ten and three freak twenty
three said seven nine ten and thirteen
one why not why not all of that yep
why not both arteris said ten is the
best final fantasy seven a close second
south pole portland said six seven eight
nine ten a lot of votes yeah thirteen
two's from dustin wow
13 too
i think you're in the minority but i
enjoyed 13.
i i know not a lot of people did but i
enjoyed it a lot
type o was dope said dustin
another vote for final fantasy 7 another
vote for seven another vote for eight
wow it's divided it's very divided
yeah my top two are seven and ten so
anyone who votes seven
over on twitch we've got votes for seven
type o
six
two votes for six uh-huh yep six is a
good one too yeah totally
i have a friend that will argue six
until the world ends yeah like any if
you say anything else she's like no but
it's obviously six because
she'll go for hours it's very funny
okay so we parked yep we parked look at
our fancy doors we're obviously royal so
fancy before we go on this adventure
let's check out our pizza really quick
because pizza is here should we refuel
for 10 gil yes we should refuel for 10
all right so we've got our pizza here
i've got the pizza hut triple treat box
and right here you can see what the
triple treat box includes it has two
medium one-topping pizzas so we've got
tifa's veggie pizza over here okay and
then we've got noctis's
pepperoni pizza right here we also have
breadsticks with marinara sauce and we
have the ultimate hershey's chocolate
chip cookie very nice we're going to dig
into some of this also i want to show
you guys this box because i promised to
give you details about the giveaway so
pizza hut is giving away an xbox one s
and this awesome controller every hour
until december 24th and how you win this
is you order one of these triple treat
boxes they're 19.99 and you get all the
food that you just saw and you open the
flap and right here i'm in a festive box
yep they come in a festive holiday box
right here your code is on the inside so
you're going to peel it here to reveal
your code and right here let me show it
to you and back here you're gonna get a
code and you're gonna go to
pizzahut.com
xbox one and you're going to enter that
code and then you can win an xbox one s
and this awesome controller so you can
also go to the other url for it is
pizzahutxbox1s.com either one will work
so go there and try to win your own xbox
one s and get some delicious pizza so
let's show them this pizza again really
quickly
let's dig in i'm going to eat so much
pizza this holiday season now
heck yes yay
absolutely
i'm going to get some pizza
would you like a veggie slice tifa um i
will yeah all right sounds great let's
get you a veggie slice
and i'm gonna get myself some noctis
pizza
delicious let's try it out
very good
that's good
so eat pizza yeah maybe win an xbox yep
maybe with an xbox
so
other final fantasy characters that are
your favorite how about male characters
we talked about some rad ladies
yeah um waka is a good time from ten
mm-hmm blitzball player wokka he's
really sweet i don't know there's so
many good ones over the years
it's actually my favorite part about
kingdom hearts is every time you
encounter a final fantasy character
so fun absolutely would you like a
breadstick um i will pass on a
breadstick for right now but i'll be
able to get them later i'll leave that
right there what's that pepperoni doing
it's delicious noctis would approve good
i'm pretty sure let's jump back into the
game okay all right
all
right
look and see in options to turn on
subtitles get some subtitles so you can
hear what's happening to our boys yeah
perfect all right
[Music]
your pizza is delicious
good job man
[Music]
all right so when we come back to our
car chat let us know if you think we
should refuel yeah
we're on twitch and youtube so please
chat with us oh lady luna freya's
wedding dress oh
gotta get that that's very important
feature on the wedding yeah i mean you
should probably pick that very important
i feel like
i feel like she i think she'll call it
off if we forget her dress all right it
looks like we got to go into the water
she's going to be an absolute knockout
the boys are saying oh
all right well it doesn't look like i
can go in the water
so i guess i have to go up and around
all right
is this where the wedding's gonna be
this is beautiful this is beautiful
i don't think it's where the wedding's
gonna be but it's lovely
it's a great venue for a wedding yeah
right
hello everyone
none of you are dressed as cool as me
because i'm a prince
hello and welcome purchase items on sale
let's get some stuff you think all right
potions
if we need anything i think we're having
a thousand gil right now okay
but we already do have a few phoenix
down okay i think we're good i'm gonna
say good as well all right sell anything
no
we hope to see you again okay thanks man
just checking out the wares
all right so we are on twitch and
youtube
tell us what toppings you think the rest
of these boy band boys would like
so we got pepperoni for noctis
i'm going to say the big guy
i forget his name i don't know yet yep
chess showy guy yep
go to the menu i think it shows their
names
there you go gladiolus gladiolus i think
gladiolus is all about protein so i'm
going to say meatloaf meat lovers i was
going to say the same thing he's totally
meat lover's guy
[Music]
there was something to pick up back here
and i missed it
a metal scrap okay we might need it for
our car i like how he just shoves his
dude friends out of the way
look at this beautiful resort can we
just stay here on vacation
we gotta get on a ferry
this is vacation
fairy tale
welcome to golden clay all right it's i
mean it's beautiful go meet the kitty
and catch a fish from i'm afraid you're
out here up all night gaming
wow look at his whole outfit and hair
and what's your story
wow
he thinks very highly of himself dies
i mean he carries himself as such maybe
he is
that cool
the cease-fire is getting us nowhere oh
uh-oh
uh oh i feel like we're about to figure
out something very bad
yeah are we in trouble and who's
allowing us
a man of no consequence
dragon king asking tricia what's your
favorite game of 2016
that's a big loaded question right there
[Music]
i don't know yeah it's tough
what were the some of the ones that
you've liked
we both talked about overcooked earlier
and how much fun it is that's my current
game that i'm playing
a lot of
i'm also i'm loving dishonored 2
right now um it was witcher 3 was early
2016 um i don't think it counts for this
year but blood and wine probably counts
for this year
okay
um
yeah it's like shadow of mordor and
witcher 3 do they both count as last
year i'm forgetting which ones which um
but both those games i really liked i'm
playing a lot of indie games lately nice
inside the successor limits yes i i was
playing inside as well do you like it i
do like it it's so dark very creepy it's
so dark and creepy i was not expecting
it to be that messed up and creepy and
i'm just like no i have to keep watching
this kid die over and over creepy have
you been playing through the woods no no
is it is it i was expecting really scary
i get scared easily yeah it's scary so
inside scares me i think that game's
going to scare
me
guys what games scare you let us know in
the chat we're on twitch and youtube and
if you're just tuning in we're playing
final fantasy 15. it's launch day this
is all delivered by pizza abduction i
should say too oh i haven't played i
want to play that it's got puzzles and
stuff right yeah it's uh from cyan the
same people that made mister and riven
very cool
i was a kickstarter backer for it
but abduction has been great love a good
puzzle game the witness was pretty
awesome this year the win is definitely
on my list the witness is so good the
witness is really good i liked the
puzzles and the witness with the the
music those were my favorite just
because like you just hear it but some
for some people it's very difficult but
for me i i really liked it you got a
good musical ear yeah i have a good
musical ear but then there i would get
stuck on really dumb stuff too so like
you have to play it with a friend in
order to finish it i think or you're
just really smart you can finish the
whole thing yourself
props to you guys if you can
i am still going through witness i'm a
completionist so it's gonna have to
happen yeah i haven't completely
finished it yet i need to get all the
beacons
cool whip said i can't wait for the
final fantasy 17 remake yeah i know oh
goodness it's going to be so good
although they're changing the combat
style
yeah
[Music]
interesting i'm sure it'll be fine i'm
sure we'll be fine hopefully you can
hear my disappointment
passing judgment already
pull up said mail me a slice sure it's
on the way
tell us what you think about this game
over in the chat we're on youtube and
twitch right now
do we want to listen to them or stand
our ground stand your ground i don't
know i just that sounded like fun
you're like i don't know yeah i know
i've been eating pizza x-wing tan said
fatal frame yeah that game is scary
what other games scare you guys
pt was scary did you play it
that was creepy
the last of us said clifford nelson yep
creepy game
day's gone scares me i'm definitely
gonna get it why twist said
looks creepy some rough gemstones like
this one
do this
find rough gemstones okay all right
okay a gentleman's agreement head to the
mineral deposit to the mineral deposit
all right
off on our quest it's less than a mile
so we can probably run it yeah
let's run it
over on twitch
backstory and said until dawn got me to
jump scare a bit but the cheap dirty
jump scare yep that's how they get you
that is how they get you hey baxarn this
merit said the mannequins in the new
resident e demo gave a good scare yeah
oh my god i don't know if i can even
play that game it looks too scary i
definitely can't play a resident evil in
vr that's for sure yeah i would scream
so hard i tweeted out as soon as that
demo happened i tweeted out uh resident
evil and vr knew
like lana felt like nurture yeah
um and one of my good friends tweeted
out at the exact same time like so
excited for president obama
and so we were right next to each other
in twitter feeding it was
just fuzzy wants us to fight someone so
if you see any
possible battles we should show off a
fight this is one possible a cat quest
hold on what is this give me that again
let's go explore
quest
for a cat
it's a cat buddy this is a cat quest
let's can we skip through this
how come you're all alone
okay
i've got pizza hut for you so this
game's got food it's got cats it's got
boy bands
it's the ultimate final fantasy
for all
cat boy
oh someone in the chat is going to learn
a fish yeah someone in the chat asked us
to fish for the cat great okay good
we'll do that someone who's played this
before yeah someone got an edge on it
noctis can fish at the docks
try angling from a fishing spot
along the coast
side quests are separate adventures that
do not progress the story check side
quest destination objective from the
quest menu all right do we have time for
the kitty catering side quest or should
we move on
let's move on okay i will leave that up
let's move on okay yeah
let us know in the chat if you want us
to go back and feed that cat
if not we're gonna look for some battle
action right now we're going to okay
now there's two markers on the map uh
there's the one that furthers our quest
and it looks like one that's maybe a
crystal the gentleman at the end of the
dock that we talked to did say to
collect some kind of rough crystals to
repair a ship or something
i was too busy eating pizza
that's all right yeah that's all right
if anybody here is worried that there
will be spoilers oh that's our car if
anyone's worried that there'll be
spoilers uh from watching this it's not
true because we're actually missing a
lot of hands so we're just giving you an
amuse boosh if you will
to the meal later to the full meal later
all right oh how can we forget silent
hill yep that's on there it said
nibbling over on youtube i know there's
a million games i'm forgetting right now
kingdom new lands i think that came out
this year that's one that i play way too
much
um silent hill was very scary let us
wait to the morning
oh i have to take over ignis won't drive
at night i'll drive it now okay
let's try to sleep right
keep the recklessness to a minimum
someone want us to fight the cat we
can't fight that cat
we're gonna feed the cat later
let's rob the dog out okay i'm driving
yep we are driving rather dark out you
sure you can handle this i can see fine
take a look
we've got these sweet sweet headlights
oh driving in the dark yeah man all
right
i think we'll run into some trouble on
the road we might i might oh
if you guys are just tuning in trisha
hershberger is here we're playing final
fantasy 15 and this is all delivered by
pizza hut yeah we're eating this
delicious triple treat box that they
sent over it's got two medium one
topping pizzas the ultimate hershey's
chocolate cookie and some bread sticks
yum yum yum
and also when you order one of those
triple treat boxes you can win an xbox
one s and this awesome pizza hut
controller
it's a custom pizza hut xbox one
controller and that comes
if you win
the giveaway which you can enter on
pizza hut xbox ones.com or
pizzahutxbox1s.com
type that in get the code from the
triple treat box and they're giving it
away once every hour until december 24th
pretty awesome so this is good to know
if you're not so into the driving sim it
just did tell us you can fast travel to
any place you've parked before which is
nice that is nice if that's not your jam
yeah that makes it a little bit easier
we just pass it
you sure we're in the right spot
stop backseat driving bro
we have to walk yeah you're gonna we're
gonna walk a little or we can get back
in oh someone wanted you to play
something on the radio can you do that
uh probably yeah i would imagine we can
when we're driving again yeah i will
hear wait i'm gonna see if i can
if i can use that uh
turn it around that i used before
let's see if i can well let's back up
there's nobody else on the road this is
very safe driving p.s
[Music]
hey everybody out
all right
all right we're at our spot okay
great
we need some more of naka's pizza right
now nice
whoa whoa oh level 15 uh-oh
okay here's here's some more combat here
we go
successful blind side strikes can lead
to chain attacks with your friends all
right let's see that sounds like fun
let's change our buddies
it doesn't look like there is
he's just coming after me oh my gosh
all right you got to carry there a
little
defend when the marker appears to carry
on coming attacks pairing an attack
creates an opening for your friends to
strike yep got it like right now perry
oh man i was trying to dodge stuff
like i said this combat is a uh we wanna
do those chain attacks overwhelming it
is
oh i'm in danger great cool got it
uh should i use oh man
should i use a potion yeah
let's use a potion
pushing on not
no no
damn it well he was in danger too
okay well but you should heal yourself
oh my gosh
thank you thank you for that someone
said run very nope get out of there
oh gosh to a new section but i can't
find a point warp anywhere right now
so i mean i guess i could
warp strike and then get out of there
come on oh no i did the evade move i i'm
doing the invade move but it's not
letting me get up that's very
frustrating i'd really like to point
work to a place that's not here
did someone heal you i don't know
approach a friend in danger and rescue
them before they before they fall in
battle that's cool so i think someone
healed you a little bit but you should
probably use a potion on yourself oh no
gladiolus is in danger all right let's
see how do i access my potions i don't
even know how i just did there we go
that was not part of the tutorial we're
all going to die yeah this is bad
everything is bad
potion on me yep
and then run to gladiolus aside and help
him out
okay well my potion on myself did
nothing did very little very
also we lost prompto
oh
these guys are why are we fighting level
30s i thought it said level 15
and now there's two level 30s are you
kidding me
is there no way to escape this
no i don't know what's happening oh gosh
really bad
okay so maybe fighting two level 30s in
a level 15 right after the tutorial
probably wasn't the best idea
all right did they uh send us back to
okay let me do something none of my
buttons are working maybe i had a spell
put on me that takes over my mind and
then i can't do anything
oh boy
yeah i can't do shite right now oh no
nope nothing
oh this is very frustrating
i'm going to check out youtube and
twitch and see how everyone's doing
they're probably backseat gaming which i
don't know they said your level's too
low it's like yeah we know these guys
are way too strong yeah i don't know why
this was the next marker it told us to
go to but i would like to go back to
before we were fighting these guys
head to them they said don't try to take
on these guys can we run away i don't
know can i get in my car let me in let
me in
let me in the car
i mean all my friends are dead i don't
even care i'm like
can you revive them i have to get
married phoenix down them
oh god revive your pounds i just want to
die
someone said bad karma for not feeding
the cat
it is bad karma for not beating the guy
see it's like point warp to high ground
to recover there isn't any
i'm looking for the point warp marker
and it's not there oh boy i'm just going
to whatever this quest is
this did you leave your friends behind
yes oh wait no they're up they're up
okay it's over i just because we ran
away
okay your friends are alive again
yeah they said to get out of the red
circle good so we did that okay we're
not taking those guys on again no they
are too strong we are most huge
definitely not you're too weak to battle
them right now we need a camp it's night
time we need to camp
but we need to find a camp marker to
camp right i think so
oh here they come again they're
following me run not cool run where's
the car
i don't know this is scary at night yeah
well they did say didn't someone warn us
not to go out at night yeah
they did but it's a lot scarier at night
whoops maybe we should have stayed in
our car
that's what we get for trying to
complete the objectives too soon
we should have just fueled up made camp
had ignorance had a nice time yeah he's
a chef he can just we can sit around and
tell stories am i not gonna be able to
get back to the car now because those
guys are in the way
all right
okay
where's the car
i don't know i think was it behind us i
think that's what we're running to maybe
it goes in a circle
i'd really like to just fast travel back
to the car but you've got a third of a
mile to jog so really get our exercise
on
that car belongs to the giants now said
dan alien no
no
did we just lose our car
are we going back i think that marker
okay still is the car okay i hope so
that's what it was before at least all
right
unless we're running back to the gas
station maybe the marker was at the gas
station
we should check the map for the car
all right let's see
map
uh yeah it's it's up there yeah
return to car oh let's do that huh or we
can call can we do that yes let's return
to the car there we go
and hopefully there had to be a quicker
way
okay gil is required to rest at lodgings
makes sense
thanks guys in the chat they said you
can fast travel to your car in the menu
yep we just figured that out whoops
that's okay yeah
all right there's the car let's get back
in let's please let's get back into the
safety of our car
oh i have to drive again that's right
yep
all right so where are we going we need
to turn around
there we go everybody out
there okay we're driving and we're off
that was scary
it's very scary at night why why did he
park
because i hit a back
and i'm not used to the driving controls
we need to get away from those scary
giants
please let me back in the car i know
they are terrifying ready let's hit it
all right ready let's hit it
[Music]
there probably is a button i could press
right now to change the radio but i
don't know what it is yeah now here it
says again head to the mineral deposit
do we need to do this during the day
like are those bad guys going to come
back out
i don't know i don't know yeah
yeah i've heard a lot of the soundtrack
and it is call backs to other games
which is really exciting yeah people are
shouting out the soundtrack they're
saying nice you guys can hear it we
can't right now
i'm sure it's good i the bit of it i
heard while we were playing before was
quite good
i mean if we want to complete the
objective tonight we have to go back to
where those monsters were
up all night gaming said the mission is
up above you guys on that ledge
interesting oh up above where we were
before
okay i need just the button that does
the turn please
there we go
press up on the d-pad to turn the music
in the car oh
okay there we go
thank you guys
they said to go up the cliff
up the cliff all right so we're going to
drive up to where we were
i don't can you drive
yeah we're going to the marker okay
driving up the cliff
there we go thanks for your help in chat
guys yeah i love it
we're working together we're all playing
this together
speaking of playing this together when
you want to take over let me know oh
yeah let's switch over do you want to
take over chat how do i how do you drive
this uh so right triggers your gas and
it auto steers for you all right
okay cool
all right which v do i like
this is fine
is it behind me
uh i think i'm going past it so it
should be
um
x should flip a uee there you go so we
missed it all right there's a turn
there you go sorry
he's getting used to i haven't driven
this yet uh sir sits a lot says any
major story points happened yet not
yeah we're we're getting excited about
noctis's wedding
and uh still in travels we're starting
to get little hints that maybe stuff's
not necessarily going awesome yeah
uh visually z draws the the game looks
great so far yes
yeah it's funny with all the aaa titles
that come out for the newer
concerts you're like oh that's so
beautiful we passed it again how do we
get up there
oh we passed it because it's up higher
yeah it's up much higher um i guess
maybe go to where it is park and then
try to get up
in there that would be my guess but i
think that's also how we ended up
fighting those guys pretty much way too
big for this
so we're definitely going downhill now
so i don't know
where we're supposed to go game delay
says just camp a suggestion i think it's
a great suggestion but i believe from
what we learned from the tutorial yeah
you need a camping spot and i don't know
how to find one of those on the map
maybe we could do that by going into
options through the map perhaps let's
see
how did you you just pressed a button to
camp last time
uh i had to find a campus spa and then
it gave me the option to camp once i
found the camping spot okay yep
all right so it's up on this ledge i
think dustin hancock says what's the
total play time for this game i have
heard total play time for main
objectives only is just over 20 hours
like 22-ish um but that if you want to
do all the side quests and you're a
completionist then it can take 55 plus
hours which i would say is pretty
standard for a final fantasy game
okay
it looks like to be on the mini map says
up all night gaming if we want to camp
we need to go to the mini map oh god oh
god
what happened to me no no i was just
trying to get up this hill run run run
out of the red circle so see the red
circle on the map
get out of that and then i think maybe
let's go with that camping suggestion
okay
let's do that
sounds good
getting out of here
all right
so go to the menu
yeah
not this menu not that this menu okay
and let's see what do we do
gear where would i look under nap map
and we're looking for a camping spot
mm-hmm all right so
minerals we can just return to a rest
point which is interesting but
let's do that
um what do you think
well we're out so far already do you see
anything that looks like a tent on that
map
i don't really not really
treasure spot treasure spot ice deposit
food spot mineral deposit
okay so maybe return to wrath point
let's return to the last point
oh campground there we go
perfect that's exactly what we're
looking for
okay how are you guys doing over on
twitch and youtube
what should we talk about with them up
all night gaming
on youtube says there's the camp site
with the smoke coming up that's what it
looks like
um and yes for everyone who's asking
when this is coming to pc or if it's
available on pc it's not currently
available on pc and i don't think a pc
uh launch date has been announced at
this point it's just playstation 4 and
xbox one
that is correct
for myself as well so i will eagerly
await i'm a new pc gamer i just started
this year yeah i got a nice gaming
laptop but i'm enjoying it i'm playing a
lot of killing floor 2 on pc
um
yeah having a good time uh backstory
says wedding so this is hangover six the
boy band edition yeah kind of at least
the beginning of the game is pretty so
far
okay so now that we're camping so how do
we camp you'll see like a blue circle
okay
and you just walk towards it
oh right there you go here we go
excellent yes let's camp because it's
too scary at night
yeah camper train
could crash right here
okay so maybe this was the campground we
were at by cindy's
probably they probably took us to the
last one we were at
toaster on twitch says tifa cosplay tifa
cosplay indeed
yeah man this is trisha i know she's
dressed as tifa hi guys i'm trisha
hershberger if you're just tuning in uh
and i'm getting to come hang out with
chastity today for the final fantasy 15
live all delivered by pizza hut
delivered by pizza hut
yeah and so i know tifa's not in this
game but since she's one of my favorite
final fantasy characters of all times i
wanted to wear it today
let's do this because i think we need
some health
all right toasty rice balls for everyone
thanks chef
yeah dad fox says it'll happen
eventually i'm sure they've been adding
more and more final fantasy games to
steam indeed they have yes
look at that looks delicious i love the
food in this game and how delicious it
looks
yum yum
okay cool
great we got some food and what bonus
did that give us did you see hp okay
by 50. great
ah
we're having a nice time
so everybody's eating their toasty rice
balls
and chit chatting with each other and
healing and yeah that's when we level up
too so now everybody's leveled up hooray
which is great skill level up
ignis is almost cooking level two uh
pronto is doing great with the
photography very nice
noctis did not do well with his fishing
because we skipped it look at this one
oh my god look at that photo
very sexy wait look at his gloves
they're really selling this boy band i
think i i might have to do a lady ignis
cosby
right just for the gloves you know what
i mean
get the fauxhawk
get the sweet chain mail gloves i would
do a lady noctis yeah yeah i'd be asking
that wig we should make that house make
that happen
all right it's daytime it's a little bit
safer it's uh i pray i'm gonna guess
it's a lot safer
and now we can hopefully get this quest
because now we can see
it was way too dark and so scary those
beasts were terrifying
yeah as soon as well i was like okay
level 15 bomb we're each like level
three and there's four of us so
mathematically that makes us a 12 but if
we're really awesome maybe we can get
them and then it's like two level 30
huge dudes with blades come out
no no no no not gonna work no it didn't
work we got trashed
all right so auto means you want ignis
to drive yeah annual means you're
driving quest location
please drive for us
gentlemen the cat's still waiting and
it's on there that cat has cursed us
so because we didn't feed it i know the
cat's real mad i feel bad i think we
should have fed that cat the cat's real
mad all right still cats
taking a walk on the wild side
[Music]
all right do we have to
are we close to it
why are we stopping it's up on the ledge
right mm-hmm is that why he stopped here
maybe
i guess that's the closest parking spot
for the quest location all right
so yeah i guess it's up on that ledge
how do we get up there let's find out
all right i think
winner winner chicken dinner yep
guys we're hanging out on twitch and
youtube if you want to ask us any
questions
talk about the game
thank you for coaching us on this game
because this is our very first time
playing
lusitanium on twitch says the cat is a
black mage
yes the cat cursed us because we didn't
feed it now i have regrets uh-oh omg
someone said
we're supposed to get near that thing
okay uh-oh
uh oh wow
there's a big ol
thing behind this wrong i can't see what
it is it looks like a bird a friend or
foe let's find out
whoa wow
it's sitting on it it's telling us we
have to go is it sitting on one we can
go around it
do we have to go around the front of it
though
and can you go around the back of it and
seem to save her yeah
sleeping bird it won't let me oh no you
have to go around the front of it
excuse me bird
oh no now we're in combat
right is that what that means
i don't know
ah i feel like that's what that red line
means should i just fight
what does the chat want me to do do they
want me to fight
let's
see go around it to the left it says
gaming oh no
got it just be real oh it's behind him
ha ha
good really sneaky like i thought he was
sitting on whatever we needed nadax says
it's a huge chocobo
look at that big bird that's not a chest
that's the darkest scariest chocobo i've
ever seen in my life goth chocobo
all right here we go
i found what we need we just have to be
very quiet and sneaky okay pick it up
head to the mineral deposit okay cool
give dino the stone
so we don't do anything with this guy we
just avoid him because he's very large
and scary and we don't want to make him
angry i think that's a stellar plan all
right back to the car
i'm just gonna take the shortcut it
won't let me all right
it's like you're close enough to the car
what do you think you're doing either
that or it's like you can't get out of
this that easy what if he wakes up on
the way back i'm gonna have to skulk
around him what look he's terrifying oh
my god so i guess maybe the red's a
warning maybe the red's like you're
getting a lot close
is this supposed to happen i don't know
but can i jump around this cliff look at
his two sets of wings though that's
beautiful
god
oh my god oh my god oh no he's just
flying away it's just gorgeous
wow oh beautiful
oh okay yeah really nice we spooked him
we're fine
we just scared him oh gosh i thought i
was gonna have to fight him
i was like i'm not ready
we made it out alive
wow whatever that was
glad we didn't have to fight it
i'm glad too
if you guys are just tuning in we're
here for another half hour roughly we're
playing final fantasy 15. it's launch
day this is all delivered by pizza hut
and i'm hanging out with trisha
hershberger who's dressed as tifa one of
the best characters ever
tivo lockhart i know i want to do a lulu
cosplay so bad because the sweet belt
dress i'm not really tall enough for
lulu
but i could try
you should do it anyway
okay
there's the car
we're also hanging out on twitch and
youtube if you want to hang out with us
tell us what you think of the game
help us play rockstar julian says holy
guacamole and that big thing yeah that
thing was
ginormous
okay
going to
yeah lucky for us he wasn't in a bad
mood good call
mm-hmm
yes fast travel because oh gosh 10 gil
time
same amount of time fishing it's
reminding us that we left a cat and we
didn't feed it
we're haunted by this cat that's
noctis's area of expertise oh so that's
interesting that's why they want us to
do it so much because we need to level
him up if that's his area let's do that
ignis is cooking mm-hmm and i'm glad
you'll see
to cook for us
makes sense gladiolus was survival
skills and uh promto's the photographer
got it they all have their roles their
boy band roles
interesting skills to make up a party
yes
very interesting
so we're gonna return this and maybe
we'll go talk to that cat again i feel
really bad about it i feel like i can't
go on without feeding the cat
it's over there uh quasar 90 says trisha
i've missed you where have you been i've
been on the internets come find me on
the youtubes and the twitches yeah all
over
follow her on twitter
yeah tell them your twitter handle that
girl trish with no eye in the girl yeah
i'm doing um
i have a bunch of shows that i do right
now weekly for kingston
and geek and sundry a bunch of stuff and
then i have my youtube channel and my
twitch channel as well yeah come play
hang out with us she's awesome yay
all right we are gonna
get this done and then i need to feed
this cat i forgot where he is do you
remember where he was yeah he's down
here a little ways i'll finish this
class
i'll finish the quest and then i'll feed
the poor there he is sam
oh kitty
he's like i'm still hungry
it's been a day and i haven't eaten
anything you guys are sitting there
eating pizza hut and i'm starving over
here on the docks
oh he's so mad at us must be nice to be
you guys
nice to have food
i don't know why final fantasy didn't
hire me to do the yes you should have
been the cat you
should god
hilarious
hi downstairs thank you hello
all right
all right
yes here's your stone i almost died and
got eaten getting it for you
nice work kid
sorry i had such a hard time
yeah dude that was dangerous dude he is
in a boy band too look at him halo x fan
2025 says can you swim in this game not
that i've found so far i tried running
into the water and it stopped
maybe later i don't know we'll see
uh in this game but also in if anyone
saw uh saw king's glaze
the oh yeah
if you saw that you know you kind of
know what's going to happen so i don't
want to spoil anything
for people who are this is their first
entry into this universe
um because we do know a little but if it
wasn't i will say it wasn't a great room
it's like watching a really long series
of cutscenes um but the voice acting was
great and it gives you background into
this world and this story so if that's
something you're interested in if you
like to know every little detail then
check it out you need to go back to this
cat
before i go anywhere sean bean and lena
heady do some of the voice acting in it
they're great
okay
i'm going back to the cat because i have
regrets we're gonna fish now i feel like
we suffered because the cat was mad at
us
a lot of people on both youtube and
twitch talking about uh porting to steam
i agree i agree with you wholeheartedly
so we just have to keep our fingers
crossed that it happens soon yeah i want
to see this beautiful game on pc as well
[Music]
all right
how do i fish oh some people in chat uh
on twitch are saying that they did watch
the movie cool cool
how do i fish
uh so uh i would go to the quest again
yeah i hit a yeah
nothing's happening
uh i guess he said originally when he
talked to us about it there were fishing
markers oh okay so so
let's go to the fishing markers maybe um
down on the other port perhaps let's see
wait not this one
kitty catering there you go
okay did you just make that our new
quest point yeah right down there
oh it was pretty lady's dress we just
ran by
yeah the outfits in this are
very stylish 24 arvid in 83 says many
people said the movie was supposed to be
the parts of the game that were cut out
oh that's why it
felt like a bunch of cutscenes yeah
because it was
i think i didn't enjoy the seaside this
much
sounds like it's made it good love the
music says jason on youtube
i bet it's good we can't hear it in here
all right so time to go fishing
let's hope that oh here's another game i
really like this here stardew valley
let's hope that uh that fishing is
easier in final fantasy 18 than it is in
stardew valley picked up the star shell
i was not good were you did you fish in
stardew valley
i heard it was easier with the
controller than the keyboard mouse which
is what i was playing with do i need to
buy anything or just can i just fish
yeah that looks like you can buy fish
there i mean if you want to cheat we
could just buy the cows
and be like
i totally called this spring
the cat's going to call us a liar that
looks like a fishing pole i want to do
it the right way this will be okay
outside the crown city fishing
dustin hancock i love your idea dustin
hancock on youtube says square enix
should give a car like that away oh my
gosh yes right
right choose where to cast your lure
with l the marker
will indicate if they're a fish near
your target i uh worked with a show
called super gamer builds where we would
take cool items from games and build
them in real life and then give them
away to like a super fan
it was awesome and now all i can think
about is having them build the regalia
oh yes that'd be very cool press a to
cast your line
do it all right we're fishing nice
fishing
move your lure by pressing right trigger
to reel it in and tilting it's tilting
that's what we're doing got it okay
a fish is eyeing your lure entice it to
bite by mixing up your wheel speed
all right all right
oh was that a fish over there
no those are bird shadows yeah we are
fishing right now we're trying to feed
this cat
got
tension that way the fish is trying to
get away silts in the direction yep okay
got it
give me that fish fish give me that fish
that way come our fish
that's okay reel the fish and wear down
the stamina okay
hi vasco in switzerland nebraska says hi
from switzerland and i want to know your
opinion how much score 0 to 10 do we
give for the game so far um we're pretty
early in the game so i don't think i can
give it a fair judgment yet because we
haven't really experienced much yet this
is very early on i feel like we need to
put in way more hours to give it a good
judgment but based on what we've played
so far i like it and i
i don't know what do you think six seven
uh yeah
the nice the nice part about a fan of
fantasy game for me is the story and
we've barely scratched the surface of it
i don't know what's happening in this
game yet i like the shout outs to other
games via the soundtrack um the visuals
are really cool in it so far the combat
mechanics are a bit wonky for me only
because i'm not used to them right now
uh but with probably another 10 i would
say with another 10 hours this could be
a solid
eight and a half nine nine and a half
for me yeah um but for right now for
right now it's like a seven because we
haven't seen anything yet and it depends
on the the conclusion of the storyline
you know when we get to the super high
points like if it's a game that's going
to stick with me
for a long time or not that's when we
based on that oh wow look at that fish
oh my gosh i hope i can get it i got a
big fish y'all got a big old fish she
got a big i need a fish please please oh
what is happening it broke did it break
it break i don't know
it's uh or no line equipped okay we had
to equip a new line i guess gosh darn it
he was huge big old fish yeah
that's all right you're getting selected
new line and laura okay okay
all right yes let's feed i got it fish
already got one i don't need to bring
him a joke oh look at that
and just swing into the air and it
disappears that's mighty nice that is
nice all right i wonder if that's
another one of his uh royalty powers
like his uh blade warp and point warp
that's all because he's in the royal
family
prince noctis
running around
where's the cat hi spiderman 1337.
spiderman
he runs like an emo boy with having a
tantrum
go go go go to the fish
okay toggle the stamina bar on or off
and i'm wondering too uh people that
have looked into this i'm sure a quick
google search could probably take care
of this or chastity if you know
but the uh the sun and the thirteen it's
just on the top left of our map there
because we're now 14.
do you know what that means no i don't
it gives me flashbacks to the original
final fantasies where you would see them
is it hours meaning of hell
maybe
what you didn't like the fish i
what
you only like cooked fish oh
this is a fancy cat
mother of girl okay
wow this cat is spoiled and demanding
that this cat is so demanding i do kind
of like that we can talk to cats yes
that is pretty great it's special
it smells pretty fun okay if parcel
tongue is talking to snakes what do you
think talking to cats is named uh
meow sultan now
you guys you heard it first yeah
[Music]
can you cook this fish for this cat i
just met please she's like this is a
waste of my time what are you talking
about
the atharva keeps asking the favorite
question uh that we're asking everyone
which is what's your favorite final
fantasy game
[Music]
so you're gonna say seven
yeah i mean i'm one of the weird people
at like thirteen a lot but okay yeah but
hey
it's not my favorite i promise it's not
my favorite seven but thirteen's a
runner-up
seven and ten and thirteen i don't know
why 13 is on there i just i it was at
the right time of my life i go back and
forth between seven and ten but i would
say right now
probably ten
with seven being a very close second but
they flip-flop for me oh what is this we
can eat we can hide i'm just trying to
talk to this lady so she could cook my
fish do i need to like go up to her oh
because i sat down
i see it's like
lady
yeah scared okay so yeah dad sit down
there's so can you jump over the bar
okay quest
quest request
talk to me lady excuse me ma'am i need
to cook a fish for a cat oh that's
probably chat go to the first one there
you go talk no there's no information
she is the chef
i'm just trying to do the quest thing
hey thank you
all right
is that the best pickup line
there's this that was funny because it's
just chad dialogue that was funny i know
the feline you've got it i've got people
in chat doing something good archerus
says ten and seven are the best in my
opinion dustin hancock on youtube asks
can you fight in the water like on final
fantasy 10 not that we've seen yet
maybe but we're only yet
[Music]
yeah
so guys the whole reason that we're here
streaming today is uh we're here
streaming final fantasy 15 on it's
launch day delivered by pizza
um and so we've got a couple of boxes
here and we've got that sweet box that
it comes in so you get a triple treat
box the triple treat box that gives you
uh what is it it's two medium one
chopping eating he says one order of
bread sticks and this is delicious
ultimate hershey's chocolate chip cookie
yum ultimate hershey's chocolate chip
cookie and a chance to win an xbox one s
with the custom controller here it is
the custom controller
that looks like this
all from pizza hut so that's what we're
doing today so yeah so i've already
eaten
two slices of pizza and i'm on my second
slice now and uh and i'm gonna go for
one of these hershey chocolate things
because that looks amazing yep and if
you guys want to win an xbox one s and
that custom pizza controller you have to
go to
pizzahutxbox1s.com for those details
so yeah thanks for tuning in everybody
um i'm curious how many of you at home
are playing this today yourselves or if
you're going to hold out and kind of
wait to get it to see
what everybody else is doing
i have to give the fish to someone else
i thought that
cooked it i can't hear her so i know did
she not take it she didn't even cook the
fish
all right please cook my fish
here we go
cool
does she think that we're just hitting
on her and we just need her to cook fish
johnny boy that was clever i do know
what you mean
johnny boyce yes i'm sorry this is funny
i'd like to limit break that chick on
the left if you know what i mean i am
already reading it because
it's the only reason it's the only thing
now can i feed the cat
i just need to get this over with so
it's not
haunting me anymore okay
feed that cat feed the cat feed the cat
look and we're all full hp yes full mp
for noctis it's good it is good
all right here you go are you happy
are you happy
see that's what i said noctis
one spoiled cat complete hooray
catering what do we get for that
claude is way to your heart well we
gotta even unlocked a new xbox
achievement
hooray thank you all right what's next
now let's get on the uh
back to our quest back to our regular
scheduled program
all right quest yep gentlemen's
agreement let's set that point all right
cool
back here yep and he has to let us on
board
ask dino to get you on board we'll do
smells good i can move on with my life
now that i've fed that cat
so it's our first side 12 22. oh we're
almost done with our stream oh
but i just fed the cat and i have pizza
fantasy 15. i could just play this all
day we can just hang out with the pizza
all day
uh nadex says i wonder when we will see
luna freya i agree i'm anxious to see
her we so we saw her 12 years ago
and for those of you who are just tuning
in now noctis the guy that we're playing
is on his way to his wedding day to
marry lunafreya
yep
yes we wish to continue please take us
on our okay great complete so we have
seven minutes left in our stream we'll
keep playing
and we just
did the gentleman's agreements and now
we are moving on yeah oh we've got a cut
scene
it's cool let's see
it's so dark and mysterious
[Music]
cool
all right
let's do
cool
shall we
do
exp
so we're hanging out for seven more
minutes in the chat on twitch and
youtube we're playing final fantasy 15.
let us know what you think of the game
and ask us any questions and we'll try
to get to them before we have to leave
we've had so much fun with you guys
thank you for helping us when we were in
the dark and just scared yeah up all
night incredibly helpful thank you
okay we got some cool pictures thank you
very much
moving on silly bee says uh at gamespot
wanted to ask if i ordered the pizza hut
treat box yes
anyway uh will chastity deliver it
um i don't work for pizza hut
unfortunately just today while i'm while
i'm you know
showing you guys this delicious pizza so
that's a no-no sorry
if you were like literally next door i
would do it
yeah
okay
oh wow
oh look at that oh so fancy
not good fancy
wow look at those weapons this is
gorgeous
gorgeously heartbreaking oh no
what
is under attack not good this is bad
this is very bad
you can tell that guy's the bad guy yep
you can you can just tell just look at
him
the guy with no face
it kind of looks like a demon
whoa
wow okay
nice character design
they've got some serious guns
they're blowing stuff up
we're in very big trouble here
it's a disaster
meanwhile we're just going around
feeding
fish to cats
our whole like
kingdom is under attack whoa
oh no
this is so bad no
i wasn't home
that was very sad
so that just kind of popped in there
yeah like a wow game is gonna what a
depressing end to our stream indeed we
have five minutes left and we just lost
our dad mostly did he just dream that
he's like guys i just had a really bad
guy guys i jumped the whole kingdom blew
up and there was crazy monster and it
had gigantic guns and it blew up my dad
i want to see what the moment is that he
realized like did we just hear that from
people that happened right a phone call
not sure if that was dream or real
should be back any minute now where's
spam in it now
well look at this fancy place we're
staying yeah this is the best airbnb
i've ever seen
holy crap
all right oh he's going to discover it
oh no did you guys read the news today
what's that look for uh oh the
heartbreaking scene
it's all in oh it is newspapers it's all
in the papers
insomnia
insomnia
falls
[Music]
i need you to calm down why would we
joke about this doctor
that was an attack the imperial
[Music]
the king was found dead
my dad
forget the wedding dudes
your whole home is in trouble
yeah what's he gonna do now yeah
i think you have to stall the wedding
dude you didn't realize his hair was
blue
guys this is okay this
how are they doing over in chat are they
all so sad are they sad that the dad
died
um
let's see
printed strategy guide i stream on
friday and sunday mornings to answer
that question um manchester says at
least my hair is in place
it's very true
no the city has fallen but my hair is
still on point
silly bee it's actually the other way
around uh kingdom hearts uh takes
characters from the final fantasy games
indeed
uh chuggins says so confused about the
story of this game the whole country has
gone to bleep and all this dude cares
about us
i think it's a little bit more than that
but yes you're on the right track
but my girl and my wedding and let's see
what's going on over on the youtubes at
two minutes cj range says you need to
watch the movie
yeah i should watch the movie
i'll check it out
all right trish has already seen it
uh yes i've seen parts of it although i
feel like after playing this game i
should go back and re-watch
so before we end the stream i just want
to show you guys this cool pizza hut
controller one more time
final fantasy 15 was delivered by pizza
hut today and you can win this awesome
pizza hut xbox one controller plus an
xbox one s by going to
com pizzahutxbox1s.com look at those
details it involves ordering your own
triple tree box which we got today and
there's a code on the inside flap of the
box you enter it on that website and you
can win they're giving away one every
hour until the 24th so you definitely
get the pizza and maybe also an xbox one
s yup yup so let me show you very cool
now that's on us here it is one more
time
yep
and now we're back in the game but we
are wrapping up the stream so we're
gonna have to say goodbye to our pals
seriously any more questions in the chat
before we go let's see let's see yeah
some people are saying don't watch the
movie the movie wasn't that good oh no
up all night says thanks for the stream
guys it was fun and you made me hungry
now i want pizza
yeah um uh forgotten toothpick says
kingsglaive is a must-watch for the
relationship with the boys again back to
that movie
let's see let's see uh cookie monster
says is that controller exclusive to
pizza hut and game
is it control yes yes the controller is
exclusive to pizza hut i don't know if
you were asking pizza hut on gamespot
and so the code that you get when you
order this pizza triple treat box is
right here on the inside flat so thank
you guys so much for joining us i'm
chassis you can follow me on twitter at
chastity underscore v this is trish
thank you so much for having me justin
thank you for joining me this was so
much fun to come up here and play with
you guys i've been dying to play this
game for oh i don't know like a decade
um so it's really exciting to play the
game it's very fun to be here and play
games with you of course yeah where can
they find you yeah guys if you're
looking for more stuff that i do
twitch.tv
hershberger youtube.com tricia
hershberger or on twitter facebook
snapchat instagram at that girl trish
with no eye in the girl so there it
thanks for joining us bye guys thank you
guys so much see you later
[Music]
you